[Musik]
etwas wundervolles passiert und zwar ist
heute ein paket bei mir angekommen
youtube ist die plattform auf der wir
uns gerade befinden
es entwickelt heute würde ich sagen der
regierung schickt youtube mehrere ein
paket das kann eigentlich nichts gutes
bedeuten ist in diesem paket der
silberne play button für meinen
zweikanal diesen kanal namens luke für
habe ich vor einigen wochen erstellt
oder einfach zuschauen wie schnell ihr
also die luke hundert tausend abonnenten
über einen vergleich machen können ich
habe euch sieben tage zeit gegeben und
ihr habt seid innerhalb von ein paar
stunden geschafft mir fließt gerade das
ganze blut im pop habe ich versprochen
dass ich die silbernen play button also
dieses silver award diesen preis den man
von youtube bekommt wenn der eigenen
kanal hundert tausend abonnenten
erreicht ich hab ich versprochen dass
ich euch diesen kanal schenken werden
also einem von euch stadtkanal gesagt
ich möchte ich verlust in den kanal
behalte ich allerdings sagen wir packen
den silbernen play button erstmal
zusammen aus
ein stift angerollt von ganz oben von
youtube laden das hier meine
ist der film der sieht ja viel geiler
aus als meiner also sie haben ein
goldener play button aus der wiki
einfach 30 kilo
das waren früher die silbernen play
buttons die herden habe ich hier für
kontrast und hierfür eine zweitkamera
luca und jetzt hier der ist geiler alter
der ist größer und der sieht cooler aus
mann ich will ihn nicht weggeben
allerdings habe ich ihm versprochen dass
wenn wir 100 tausend abonnenten auf dem
youtube-kanal innerhalb von einer woche
erreichen sollte das sich an diesen
button an euch verlosen werde so einer
von euch hat die möglichkeit diesen
button demnächst selber in den händen zu
halten und sich ins zimmer hängen zu
können also ist was ihr dafür tun müsst
ist jetzt einfach unten die beschreibung
zu gehen dort habe ich euch nämlich das
video auf dem youtube-kanal verlinkt
weil wir sollen ja nur auch abonnenten
von dem youtube-kanal die chance haben
das ding zu gewinnen weil die ja teil
der auf ihr wisst was man also checkt
die beschreibung erwartet ist dieses
video hier vorbei ist denn jetzt gleich
post werde ich euch das video auf dem
youtube-kanal auch noch mal verlinkt das
ist genau jetzt gerade auf online
gegangen dort erfahrt ihr alles was sie
tun muss um diesen silbernen preis des
echten rest also in dem video auf dem
kanal in dem video auf dem youtube-kanal
der vater auf jeden fall alles was ihr
wissen müsst um eventuelle diesen
silbernen reiss hier zu gewinnen also
wir sind jetzt darauf dem handel
kanal wieder und morgen kommt dann
wieder ein anderes video auf einem kanal
[Musik]